you've got two narratives one is we're
doing the best we can it's the
unvaccinated we're causing this pandemic
to go on and on and we've got the tool
at our disposal and people just need to
use it okay that's obvious nonsense but
nonetheless that's the story
um and then you've got the alternative
narrative which is actually the vaccines
interesting as they are as a
technological Discovery have multiple
design failures within them they are
weak as can be which anybody you don't
need any biological knowledge whatsoever
to recognize that if they've faded to
the point you need a booster in six
months this isn't much of a vaccine by
any standard right so but also there's
no pretense that they prevent
transmission right so and it's this
incredible cognitive dissonance this
incredible intellectual discontent
and people your friends are telling you
you can't come to my party because
you're unvaccinated and you can't even
say to them but vaccines but Tony fauci
says vaccines don't prevent transmission
right and you can tell somebody that
fact
and the reaction will be to get furious
at you rather than say oh
um and how am I protected
we know that vaccinated people are
equally likely from all the data that we
have
to pass the illness they may you know
there's a lot of data that says if
you're vaccinated you're more likely
yeah well I can't say that's true
because
um we do not have because nobody's you
know funding the signs that show that
but the science that we have
and also common sense
and this is what Luke montenero who
discovered you know the one the Nobel
upper Heiser just got ring
the HIV virus in 1993
and what he said from the beginning if
you if you vaccinate people with what
they call a leaky vaccine which is a
vaccine that does not prevent
transmission during the height of a
pandemic
you are turning every vaccinated person
into a mutant Factory you're actually
it's a each person is a a Serial passage
gain of function experiment
the same reason that sub-therapeutic
antibiotics right exactly generate
um generate uh antibiotics resistant
superbugs a vaccine that is
sub-therapeutic is gonna is by every
from anybody who understands natural
selection or biological evolution would
immediately say of course that is going
to create mutant superbugs right now and
they've played this game they've played
it with me and I don't much like it
because they accuse me of not
understanding what I'm talking about
when in fact what they're doing is just
playing a linguistic game we say Escape
mutants right that puts the emphasis on
mutation and so they make this argument
that the number of cases is is
proportional to the amount of mutation
which is of course true but it's the
selection for the mutants that are
resistant to these vaccines that is
driving this so the these are Escape
variants which is the result of
selection which is very definitely
happening in those who have been
vaccinated
what's more and this is
again very hard to convey to people who
haven't been paying attention but
covet is not the worst disease it might
be from the point of view of the
symptoms but it's very bad on its own
right it does damage to many different
types of tissue it does tags all organs
right all organs which I take to be
indicative actually of the likely origin
from the lab because most bugs have to
pay attention to you know keeping you on
your feet so you spread them but in a
laboratory things are very different if
you're spreading it in a tissue or in an
animal that doesn't have to forage right
if you are a passage and
you want your host to be eating drinking
having sex going to parties right um and
and because you the advantage goes to
the ones that are not sickening at
reorgan in their host right so this is a
bad disease and Heather and I have said
that from the beginning this is a
dangerous disease those who downplay it
were making a mistake the irony is that
this is actually changed this was a very
dangerous disease until some very good
dedicated doctors figured out how to
treat it right it is now a very
manageable disease except for the fact
that all of the tools that would prevent
it and are useful in treating it are
being removed from the table as quickly
as possible and so the idea that you
know it isn't one you know yes
Ivermectin indeed there's a really good
drug that works really well in this case
we know that from Doctor's clinical
experience likewise hydroxychloroquine
but even if you take those off the table
we still have a whole host of substances
that work and we actually in fact have
substances that prevent people from
coming down with it and yet our Public
Health response does not include a
discussion of things like vitamin D and
zinc and magnesium right this is
unconscionable right we are actually
talking about a disease that at Great
cost we have learned how to deal with it
does not require us to lock down the
world at this moment because we have
enough knowledge but we're not deploying
it and so what they've effectively left
us is a vaccine that is effectively an
interesting prototype right not nearly
well enough understood not nearly safe
enough to be deployed into the public
not Justified on the basis that it
doesn't as you point out prevent
transmission
right we have this prototype vaccine
being deployed as if it's a solution to
the pandemic and the actual Solutions
are being uh kept out of play and that
is keeping this disease much more
dangerous than it actually is or would
need to be at this point this is
preposterous it's the up upside down
inverse Public Health response and the
problem I mean really let's let's talk
about the actual problem the actual
problem is if what I just said is true
then the world is upside down that
leaves the person watching this podcast
with nothing to grab onto okay so there
are some Renegades who say we're doing
the exact inverse of what we should be
doing even if you would acknowledge that
it doesn't tell you how you change
anything so you know it leaves but I
think people are simply doubling down on
the idea that the public health
authorities must be doing the right
thing because if they're not it's
hopeless yeah and it's hard you you know
you discredit yourself and marginalize
yourself if you
even by inventorying all the like bad
things they do because the the
um
the
conclusion that you kind of growl
yourself into is feeling like a you know
a lot of evidence that they're
deliberately doing things that they know
are wrong to harm public health and you
know that's
for most people that's
um it's impossible
[Music]
foreign